parabola basically is this u-shaped
graph right it can be opening up or down
or right or left right and the distance
from the vertex which is the point where
the parabola bends and this imaginary
line we call the directrix right here
that distance we call P and P is also
the distance from the vertex the focus
and that's the point right there and
basically what a parabola is it's the
set of all points such that any point on
this parabola is going to be the same
distance between a given point called
the focus and a giving line called the
directrix so you can see as you go
further out on this parabola the
distance to the focus is getting longer
so as the distance to the directrix
but there's distances are gonna be the
same so that's what a parabola is but as
far as you know the equation it's either
gonna be an x squared variety like x
squared equals 4p Y or what I call a Y
squared variety which is Y squared
equals 4p X and if it's the x squared
term if the X is a term that's squared
it opens up or down okay if P is
positive it opens up okay if P is
negative it opens down and then if it's
a Y squared variety opens right or left
it opens to the right if P is positive
left if P is negative and then you can
see you can also write it in a more
general way right here with the h and
the K the h and the K pick up the graph
shift it left and right up and down if
any of this seems confusing to you I'll
have links to other videos that I did
you know talking about some of the more
basic and introductory level parabolas
and in this type of form here so but
let's see if we can can take a look at
this example here so basically they're
giving us the vertex is four negative
two the directrix is y equals two but I
wanted to mention before I get into this
equation and graphing this parabola if
you're preparing for the AC T or the SAT
and you want to boost your score and
improve your grade on that important
test check out my huge a CT math review
video course in my huge SAT math review
video course I go through teaching and
examples and it's got numbers of hours
worth of video in there with a lot of
opportunities for you to practice and we
focus on specifically problems that
you're expected to know on those tests
so you're better prepared you know what
to expect and you'll know how to
approach those problems so go ahead and
take a look at some of the previews I've
got a few free previews for each of
those courses to see if it's right for
you but if you're looking to boost your
score definitely check those out
a lot of students have taken them and
have reported back that that's really
helped them improve their score and if
it's right for you then I definitely
encourage you to check that out but
let's go through this problem now so the
vertex is 4 negative 2 so you're going
right for down to okay so that's the
vertex right there and the directorís is
y equals 2 now remember y equals lines
those are horizontal lines right okay so
now what we want to do is we want to
realize that the distance from the
vertex to the directrix is our p value
so you can see here if this is going 1 2
3 4 so you can see that from here to
here that's P P is equal to 4 also if
you go from the vertex to the focus that
distance is 4 so 1 2 3 4 it's gonna be
right down here there's our focus right
ok that distance is also P and then at
the level of the focus I didn't mention
this in the intro but the width of the
parabola okay at the level to focus this
width right here is always going to be 4
P so in this case since P is 4 it's
actually going to be 4 times 4 is 16
wide so what I would do is from the
focus here I would go right 8th and I
would go left 8 okay so let's see how
much is that right here so it's gonna be
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 right about over here so
that gives you an idea about how wide
okay
the parabola is at the level the focus
okay but as far as the equation goes
because it's opening down we know this
is going to be an x squared variety so
it's gonna be X - let's see now the
vertex is at 4 negative 2 so it's going
to be X minus 4 squared equals 4 times P
4 times 4 is 16 but this is going to be
a negative 16 since its opening down if
it was opening up would be a positive 16
and then we've got Y plus 2 now notice
these are the opposite sign it's X minus
the x-coordinate of vertex y minus the
y-coordinate of the vertex and because
this x squared is opening down and we
have our 4 times P as our coefficient
right here so I hope that helps you to
understand how to write the equation of
a parabola when you're given the vertex
and the directrix if you have more
questions about you know how this whole
process works if there was something
there little bit confusing there I'll
have
two other videos I did talking about the
introduction and the more basic level
problems so you can check out those
videos as well so subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon